back again back again blonde first time
you get me taking over New York you're
only no mile at troops let's do this
thing
would you rather the world lost women or
all sports are trying to [ __ ] me on this
one in it you think you're smart in a
blood all women on all sports blood says
I have an arsenal or pump up a Bama yang
or head Astley a denier broth blood what
can I say my hand can only last so long
you got me if you had the opportunity to
turn someone into a [ __ ] who will it
be
you are taking a piss how can I say this
[ __ ] blood who would I turn into a
[ __ ] oh my god Kroenke would look
funny as a [ __ ] he looks funny already
where that dumb toupee
Robbie Madden Robbie has a [ __ ] blood
he look like an oompa loompa cuz he's
got a bit of wit finit lat if you found
the porn if you found a porn online of
your buddy and his girlfriend would you
watch him would you say anything to him
would you
it depends what friend you know yeah
depend depends what friend would I say
anything to him the Pens were friend
again as well it's mad because like you
come back to it your boys in it you can
go down you understand freak out free
man calm but when it's his wife it's
very different now I understand like
it's it's not like a it's not like a
[ __ ] you know I mean so I probably
wouldn't watch it but and I probably
tell him store I'm gonna laugh oh god
really
really really I'm gonna get meme for
this one me men wherever the [ __ ] they
call it I'm getting fun this videos
gonna for my lifeblood would you rather
be Magic Johnson
with AIDS or a regular dude with no AIDS
everyone knows magic Johnson blood hello
money don't know about healthy dough but
looks and what is inside these are
different you get me and maybe that
Johnson ain't too magical right now you
get me so I'm gonna have to be a normal
but up
whoa would you kill baby Hitler if it
had to be in a very gruesome way how
gruesome so this is baby Hitler so this
is Hitler's is this Hitler or Hitler's
baby I'll do madness bro yeah I'll do
madness bro because he knows what he's
doing is probably got a little mo
started a [ __ ] weirdo I'm telling you
blood would you rather have one giant
dick forearm or have all four fingers be
dicks oh my god this is the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] four fingers as four fingers will
be dicks so this will not be a finger
this will be foreskin for that blood for
that fan is man mad dog or a big dick on
my arm dog so must walk around with a
cookie like that phone so my goodness
Richie I never got a [ __ ] outta my car I
could just [ __ ] out like that on the bus
on the train it can just be a madness
blood gotta be jumping on it they'll be
like yo excuse me can I hold your arm is
that right is that an arm or is how
you're happy to see me you know I'll
have to go with the arms though I'm not
gonna lie but that'd be a bit different
laughs can you imagine that can you
imagine like getting head off your arm
and then you're banging your girl
bloodline if you're literally free see
you're free see ya
quite some acting well I'm not gonna lie
still oh my god would you would you
rather [ __ ] a chick who's banked $1,000
we talking about understand because she
could be talking about a man she could
say that man was an animal you
understand we're talking about a dog or
a sheep or a goldfish it could have been
a goldfish blood I understand you know
it's probably me
wiggling in the pom pom with a madman II
understand
Oh bang a chick but blood the worst
thing is yeah I could have already
[ __ ] a chick here who is [ __ ] an
animal and I could have [ __ ] a girl
who's been smashed by a thousand men you
understand
so you know what yeah there's a thing
called a condom so I'm gonna have to
[ __ ] the chick who's banging the
thousand man because I'm a dick no way
no way no [ __ ] animals bin block you
think I'm getting a [ __ ] tetanus in
my ass Najee entry no exit my partner
you understand
would you rather kill all no no no would
you Robert
would you rather kill 25 kittens in a
row or one dog Charlie's got a dog
Devon's cat just died and you pull this
on me has he got access to my emails or
some blood
Oh is he somehow in the group chat you
understand like twenty five kittens bro
or one dog police dog all day is what it
is would you give up sport all together
if your dog could live happy and healthy
for as long as you want it no straight
no broth bye bye r.i.p baby understand
combined new dog blood simple let's keep
it moving from I'm not buying a new team
now would you ever have teeth where your
hair is or hair where your teeth are so
teef here here here here here here
you wouldn't get bro
that I'm gonna have to do the t thing
above under ass they did the teeth in
buff I can't have that hair in my mouth
imagine you're eating food buff light
it's just hello Mac Donald's getting
stuck on your own now that blood would
you ever have a good hand job all you
son of a [ __ ] would you ever have a
good hand job from your grandmother or a
bad hand job from your bangle boy I hate
you I [ __ ] hate you okay thank you
[ __ ] bad innit man [ __ ] off get bad
one in it there's a force door bathroom
with a glory hole in each store free
with smokes and one with a dude do you
take the chance
what do you mean smokes so I don't know
who's buying the bathroom so I do I take
the John's
no it's not worth the risk blood I do
not want to see Richard greet me when I
bust that door firm understand I'm
trying to see Betty understand and then
kind of Galilee you fool me I'm not
trying to see Richard and Johnson and
him and a Magic Johnson in there Monday
I'm not in a doubt you understand I'm
trying to find pretty woman you feel me
so bye-bye they're filming one happy
blood and legit our outward man